[Music]
how are you I'm fantastic thank you for
having me I'm so happy that you're
actually here this time you were
gracious enough to let me host for you
when you are at the Olympics but it's
nice to see you and I would love for you
to host again holiday yeah you did a
great job very nice of you absolutely
did a great job Larry David came in yeah
and he keeps asking when he's coming
back I feel like he literally he's like
wait wait are you a package deal just
Larry David want to come back in and
just on yeah I made agent so yes all
bookings go sir yeah I'd love to have
Larry David back on okay let me get to
the big story two weeks ago in social
media yes you post a picture you're at
the gym working out and you put a heart
around McLovin space I did
now our show was on the TV when you were
working on so let's just clear it up
what was your motivation there I thought
and right you know I always have a thing
for people in glasses then and I saw you
and I just you you were so wonderful to
me when I was there guest hosting I know
you're married and so it's inappropriate
and Sarah with all due respect of course
but I just I think McLovin is very
attractive
it's very innocent because I respect the
two-hour part you're taken I think
McLovin fantastic I love the fact that
she knows your wife Nia so she's been
googling you ah straight to images news
portion of the program
McLovin any look at you you're you guys
are your I don't know you look nice
where you learned something different
before uh yeah I think
what the hell is wrong with you I'm not
sure I don't really comfortable talking
to women no but you did make up a girl
you did not have a girlfriend in high
school right you made up that you had a
girlfriend right well yeah I de
girlfriend Niagara Falls area she's
completely she lived into Canada and us
I'd dual citizenship replied no no no no
he's completely completely gone I
suppose over yeah nobody was interested
in this in high school but Kristin and I
understand it I told you I am the leader
of the friendzone she knows my wife's
name come on I got that I'm a friend
heart and that's I'm fine with it why
are you why are you trying to take away
my love for you I want you my voice by
the way is going if yeah whatever Iroh
I've been working you know you get it
there's a demi moore feel to it I don't
know what's happening over here but are
you gonna be ready for Sunday I hope so
yeah oh I'm finishing my
responsibilities that extra today is my
last day of taping to that and then
tomorrow we'll do rehearsals and then
Sunday my voice should be back what is
your role on Sunday on Sunday I will be
hosting an hour of the kickoff show and
then I'll be doing an hour on the red
carpet with Cooper Manning always
entertaining and for those of you that
have never seen Cooper Manning in action
he's a gem we gave him his start in New
Orleans Manning on the street did you
really yeah Paulie said let's get Cooper
Manning when we're in Norfolk well it
Fox owes you money happen here he's the
most talented Manning we invited him
first they're not the first network to
steal stuff from this show for us is
just to let people know here we go we're
gonna do this huh we're doing this
normally it's the mother ship that does
not not okay but so we're good here yeah
and then I I sat down with Matt Ryan
earlier this week so that interview will
air in the show as well okay is there a
coin toss of who gets the interview
Brady and who gets interview Matt Ryan
well I'm pretty sure the guy was for
Super Bowl rings named Carrie Bradshaw
got to energy and hungry yeah that's how
that works if you have four rings you
get to interview the guy with four rings
mmm yeah okay what did you get out you
want to tease what your work is there is
there a tear is it emotional with Matt
Matt Ryan yeah you know Matt Ryan
Matt Ryan is one of the nicest people
that you'll ever meet and for him and I
a lot of the discussion was about sort
of getting that proverbial monkey off
his back you know that an embassy
championship game is sort of all about
can he win that big game can he take his
team to the next level
so yeah it's sort of the maturation of
Matt Ryan I also saw your name in the
news mentioned for Black may be
replacing Chris Berman yeah and then
Chris Berman and I laughed about it in
the lobby of the hotel the other day I
mean look you never know but a
non-denial denial that is a big chair to
fill it's not it's definitely not on the
table the speculation is what it is I'm
very happy with my role right now a lot
but if offered it hasn't been offered
you say hypothetical no I'm very happy
at Fox I have a good thing I get to live
in California I work and get an
entertainment job and I get to do sports
so yeah I really can't complain but it's
cool though that even if your name is
mentioned however it's mentioned giving
you validation of you know being the
host of a big show like that oh sure I
mean possibly I want it I wanted to be
you know Chris Byrne that's how I got
started in this business by watching I'm
wanting to be in this business by
watching him with my father when I was a
kid so to even be mentioned even in a
very like hypothetical way is yes of
course it's flattering but it's not it's
not happening where is the industry
though do you think with looking at
women other than sideline reporters
because our way moving you know Suzy
Kolber has done a great job hosting on
the style Hill Hannah Storm but but are
we moving past because I now we're
seeing guys on the sidelines yeah almost
as much as we are women yeah and it's no
longer confined that was just great and
there's so many more media outlets as
you know I mean just the cable channels
alone so there's a lot more opportunity
I mean well I think that we should never
just be confined to one thing and the
more opportunities the better of course
what is if you could interview Brady
yeah well what would you want to know
from him so I interviewed Rob Gronkowski
was it two years ago two years ago for
the AFC Championship game he told me
that Brady doesn't shower after practice
I said what's the fun fact about Brady
we don't know he goes he doesn't shower
after practice I said what he's like the
items so I would ask them about that why
don't you shower after practice how many
times can Tom Brady be asked about a
legacy you know me I'm a little bit rope
and a contrarian like I don't want to
ask him the generic things I would do
like a rapid-fire quiz with Brady do you
think he'd play yeah you do for sure
pretty cool you've interviewed Tom Brady
yeah a long time ago and I thought he
was one of the best interviews I ever
did because he didn't know what he was
saying was headline-making
I did an interview with him free ice
cream the magazine yeah I had to remind
him you know hey you may not want to say
that like I didn't want to get him in
trouble
you're a good interviewer then he was
that comfortable where he was divulging
everything he was watching a Monday
night game at home now this is before
Giselle and all and so I I call him up
McLovin are you still here yes I then I
remember talking to him and then I would
just throw out questions and then he
would answer it in it like it's an
honest answer and I said you know I'm
just a light you know I'm recording this
and then he goes oh yeah okay fine
and then we got done and he said call me
if you need you know clarification or
follow-up and I go all right
and I bring the tape in to my editor and
he listens to it he goes holy oh yeah
you know what he's saying a lot of stuff
here but it wasn't like mean spirit as
much he was what was it about um he
talked about other quarterbacks you know
how he's viewed his lack of athleticism
he was talking about how good he can be
what people thought of him um family
what it played like role and chip on his
shoulder and motivation and will he ever
get to a point where people look at him
and say you know he's actually a really
good quarterback like he yeah he gave
thought to it yeah which I thought was
great and then all of a sudden he became
a brand and then it changes a little bit
I mean you notice in Hollywood the
people that you interview you can get
somebody who's somebody who is you know
on the side supporting actor
and all of a sudden they go big-time and
then you're away minute that's a
different person than I saw like two
years how come yeah yeah well some of
those will remain nameless but yeah oh
no that's not any fun now that I know I
already already played this game once
with you I gave you wide right that is
true I doubt that is that is true well
that's good that's nice when there's not
that filter but at the same time now
there's a lot of handlers yes great so
that you probably wouldn't have that
opportunity as Russell Wilson changed
now because you've known him a long time
he is not she is the same guy I've been
getting married to Sierra
Russell we joke in my joke he's
Hollywood you know there's but not it
he's Hollywood in medicine had a lot of
things that he didn't used to be at but
at the core of who he is no he has not
changed he's the same guy who my niece
was having a garage sale to raise money
but really he had a brain tumor so he
went to the garage sale and bought stuff
from her at the garage so you know he's
that he's still that same person my
little nephew did a video because
Russell Wilson's his favorite player so
Russell sent him a video back saying hey
man I love the book report so whether it
was three years ago or whether it's
today he's still that same person which
is so nice but that that speaks to his
bit you know his mom it keeps him that
way but we these athletes are
interviewed every day yeah celebrities
in Hollywood are not interviewed every
day if they have something to sell press
junket for a movie more challenging
though if you're sitting down with a
big-time movie star or a big-time
athlete of trying to get something out
of them and the entertainment step
absolutely is harder yeah a lot harder
because they have the publicist and the
Wranglers are right there they're never
without them like Denzel is not going to
be like walking around by himself on a
red carpet if you get like two and this
is like this is like the classic thing
in Hollywood two questions
it's like it okay so when you see the
movie poster over Denzel Washington's
head uh-huh and then you come in and sit
down then you get two questions and then
somebody else comes in right after you
right like what on a red carpet you get
two questions in a press junket you get
two three three minutes but if you say
anything I got done this before like
I'll start to because there's the list
of questions billboards that you know
well we'll get to the movie later we'd
like the 73 questions like your personal
life and what about the movie but the
pill step in they'll be like nope or
they will say we can't use it yeah give
me the worst reaction you ever gone well
in the political landscape we've been in
over the last year we've had to ask a
lot of political questions and people
don't want to talk about that some
people really want to talk about
Hollywood wanted to talk some people
really want to talk about it but some
people really don't so so the worst
reaction was from him I'm not going to
say why are you doing that got to trap
me no I didn't mean to trap you I did
I'm sorry okay
yeah like initial could you give me a
new table like a movie there I want to
go back to my affinity for McLovin so
miles teller what's up - you know miles
tell it's great he's won but yeah he's
great do you think he gave up the role
in LA he lost lala land to Ryan Gosling
did do I think he lost it yeah yeah I
would sources close to me told me that
he was for a man who are your sources
yes
you know Billy Bush is my source oh yeah
he told me I was failing
I have no idea okay I have no idea
extract yeah I'm curious about that
though I think miles teller lost the
role of lala land around Gassman and
emma watson lost the role to emma stone
is it a known thing that Matthew
McConaughey was up originally for
Titanic and oh hi this boats going
around all right
ah when we got a boat I'm gonna need a
bigger boat yeah yeah well it's certain
it's like Ryan Gosling's awesome in Long
Island I couldn't imagine miles teller
doing that well see but now you we have
a Ryan Gosling Ryan Gosling and Emma
Stone have a great relationship that's
the third movie they've worked on
together yeah it's always easy to say
like after the fact like oh yeah no I
couldn't imagine seeing that person but
if you had never seen Ryan Gosling you
went if I can say that Matthew
McConaughey would not have been better
than Leonardo in Titanic
how are you sure hi I'm an actor that's
an iceberg true you are an actor I am an
actor
what was that all right all right all
right leave that iceberg don't want a
face yeah if he wouldn't have the same
impact I think McConaughey that Southern
well yeah they were also very different
ages Leo was so much younger she's going
to ask all the important questions
coming up on Sunday she said Fox sport
NFL kickoff show host and co-host of
extra extra Christa Thompson McLovin
would you escort Kristin Thompson oh wow
yeah yeah that would gentleman go
there you go Theresa Johnson look at the
deck what a gentleman lovin you're going
the wrong way where we're walking in
circle around there one your box no
we're right ahead here you go thank you
doctor this to the Dan Patrick show the
Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience
[Music]